[Music]
foreign
liat aaronson thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
thank you for having me this is really
really great so where are you calling us
from i am in
israel which is just outside tel aviv
wonderful and is that everything okay
everybody's suffering healthy
um yep no no complaints we are uh
staying safe abiding by the rules and uh
and waiting for things to ease up
they've been easing up over the last um
week and uh hoping that it goes nice and
slow and that everyone
still maintains uh safety so that we
don't have to dig back in
definitely you know so this interview is
actually going to air i believe in the
end of may
so hopefully by then the phases are
going to be to accelerate and hopefully
everything will be
it will be perfect by then but uh time
will tell
lyat is so much to talk about over these
20 minutes
uh i have so many friends who've gone
through the zell program which you are
the executive director of
and i'd love to talk about blockchain
from horizon labs all the way to
being the on operations at salina can
you tell me a little bit about about
zell and what that was about and how
you're fostering entrepreneurship
among amongst undergraduates in the idc
sure so um you know my
my path to zell was probably not um
not very very uh intuitive i
studied uh law and was worked in mergers
and acquisitions for many years
at a big law firm in israel and i was
kind of looking for something
um a little bit more impactful to do
with my
time and although i enjoyed being a
m a lawyer it was i felt like i needed
to do something with a little bit more
meaning and i was kind of
you know shopping around i was thinking
of maybe doing a phd
um i had four small kids uh by then
and so also something that would manage
my time um was more effective with my
family
big kids in the meantime and um and a
friend of mine was working at idc and
she said you know
they're looking for someone to run an
entrepreneurship program and i thought
okay well why me i'm you know i'm i'm
not an entrepreneur i've never managed
anything and i'm
uh not an educator so i'm almost
uniquely unqualified i'd
like to say uh for this position so
um but i came out to campus and i don't
know if you've been to the idc campus
but it is a very
it's very small but it's very beautiful
and there's a little charm
some kind of you have magic in the air
it feels like a village
army base it feels like a village right
yeah absolutely it was an old army base
that was uh converted so there's not
a lot of uh trees um a lot of trees and
and just great vibe plus there's like
this little entrepreneurial spirit in
the air
um that i think professor miakman
instills i don't know if he
grows it in the flowers or something so
i i fell in love with the place it was
kind of love at first sight
and in the team although i had a
big learning curve in the first year of
just reading up a lot of the methodology
that was coming out like four steps to
the epiphany
started um lean startup and um
and i was starting to get acclimated
with uh um
with the methodology side i'd already
had a lot of contact on the ecosystem
network side and so i started combining
them together
and had a great playground to do it with
a lot of um
really wonderful people that go through
the program are humbled by
having the opportunity to spend a whole
year with 24 people that are
at a crosswords crossroads in their life
of kind of finishing undergraduate
uh degree and about to start um their
real life and then
um i was doing that for a couple of
years and then 2008 happened
which was a um a turning point for the
program and a turning point personally
for me
in the sense that um most of the people
who would come to zell before that
were really excited about um
uh becoming investment bankers but
really
yeah oh okay because it was a program
for outstanding students and they were
outstanding students and so
they went to the program for outstanding
students doesn't necessarily
want to be entrepreneurs wow okay the
disruption will
but disruption will change something and
i think that's a little bit of a
like asterisk for now i think we're in a
period of disruption and i think a lot
of things
will change and there'll be a lot of
opportunities as a part of that
and this is one of them um so there was
a total shift
um on the technology side so open source
and um iphone as a platform or the app
stores
as a platform and cloud computing so a
lot of technology changes a lot of
economic changes so a lot of highly
talented people wanting to be
entrepreneurs
or having to be entrepreneurs because
there weren't any investment banking
jobs
necessity breeds innovation and i think
that uh combined
allowed for younger entrepreneurs to be
able to be more successful so
from 2008 on we started having more and
more ventures really
out there in the world um some exits
which i'm proud of but i'm actually
prouder of the fact that i think today
there are about three thousand five
hundred people employed in
zelda alumni companies wow and that's um
welcome to the program so you know yeah
zell really just to give context to a
lot of my friends at stanford who are
viewing this
zell really is in israel the the analogy
it's analogous to the stanford business
school of the us
so really it is known as one of the best
entrepreneurship schools in israel
you know i i'm just speaking from my
from my time at 8200 and all my friends
who went through the program it's one of
the prestigious programs to get into
that a lot of people just love and
really give credit for
what do you think and but there are a
lot of a lot of entrepreneurship
programs a lot of accelerators
what do you think allowed zell to really
foster itself to becoming this hub
of of success that it's seen
um well first of all thank you for the
compliments i think stanford is
definitely
um you know up there and i think um kind
of like stanford's history which was
a lot to do with uh timing and a sense
of
um the president of the university being
able to recognize that there's an
opportunity
in combining between you know the forces
of kind of commerce and
and you know military government
spending i think the same thing was
happening here with that 2008 so
i think younger entrepreneurs were
becoming um it became
more accessible it didn't become easier
accessible and i think the idc in
particular
and zell as a conduit
were great places for hatching that and
that's because
most of our teaching um comes from real
world practitioners people who have done
in in the past
and um this program is very very
hands-on
we do have some academic courses but
most of the programming is actually
about rolling up your sleeves and trying
and failing and getting up again
it's also the echoes of sanzell who
doesn't believe there's any such thing
as a failure you just have setbacks and
then you get up
and you go again he's also not a big
believer in uh setting limitations he
just believes that he can do something
and
plows forward and i think that ethos and
the support that we got
not only from idc but also from samsung
his generous donation
were able to give a lot of um a lot of
almost like a safety net and you know if
you can kind of visualize like one of
those
safety nets but it's so tight that when
you land you actually
are able to bounce right back up almost
like a trampoline and i think that's
really what the program infrastructure
was able to harness
the entrepreneurs were kind of there i
think there's a lot at idc
not only in dell obviously a lot of
entrepreneurs in israel not only at idc
and i think zell was just um a really
ripe um
um kind of uh almost like a sandbox
for for people to try things fail
and get up again a lot of our
entrepreneurs our zelda alumni
entrepreneurs
didn't create their venture in the
program they created it even a couple of
years out we're still very close with
everyone and we're a very tight
ecosystem
and sometimes the right time isn't when
you're studying it's a couple years out
yeah and i think and i think that's
pretty comparable to a lot of
entrepreneurship accelerators
where you're fostering these skills you
have an opportunity to go and break
barriers and try
your luck at things that are very high
risk and
you don't actually fail you just have
setbacks and your next ventures you
maintain this knowledge and experience
that you've accumulated
and obviously they're still a part of
the zillow community that's huge
so now we're fast forwarding to to
selena and and horizon labs tell me a
little bit i mean selena is obviously a
well world known and a huge huge success
tell me a little bit about what
what you were doing over there and then
let's jump onto blockchain and that
type of stuff okay
just um kind of on the way between idc
and selena
two years at marker llc it was a um
a venture capital venture capital firm
it explains my how i got to selena so
it's a little segway but i
um from zell i i joined as a partner
in uh it's a new york um tel aviv based
firm
that was investing primarily in israeli
companies that were
ready to launch or kind of grow and
scale in the united states
so mostly series a and series b i joined
that firm in state for two years
i'm still involved in our follow-on fund
and um
investing in our portfolio companies and
i'm a director in one of the companies
in the portfolio but um but two years in
there was a lot of structural changes in
the fund
and it became clear that they weren't
going to focus on early stage investing
in israel and that's
kind of my passion and where i feel like
i uh can bring more to the table
plus i really missed uh kind of being
you know
in the hands-on world as opposed to you
know
the sitting and mostly getting to say no
world
which is a part and parcel of being an
investor
and being a good investor and seeing a
lot of deal flow but having to
eventually
say no so i was um i was just leaving
uh marker one of the zell alumni was
working at selena and he introduced me
to rafi the ceo and we started talking
they just raised uh their first um like
really big round
and um and they needed to kind of get
organized on
um investor relations and also building
out like what would be the
infrastructure for raising
the next round because everything had
gone so super fast yeah it was like a
lightning speed uh
yeah so i came on to kind of do a
consulting project and from that
consulting project i ended up
um morphing it really quickly into a ceo
role so i was the chief operational
operations officer not focusing not
focusing on the hotel
operations but more on corporate
operations which
so it was kind of um you know part
housekeeping um
but also part building up the
communications between the different
divisions
and that uh
the growth of the high growth and the
pace that was happening
we're also getting the kind of
infrastructure support
of building the organization so a lot of
strategy
too really really fun a lot of travel
great people incredible people um just
kind of the right of my
life but it was very very intense and
and after a year
i just realized that although i was
absolutely in love with
the operational part after you know
being hands-on
i felt like probably something smaller
would be more suitable to be so at the
time when i was still in selena
i was visiting panama about once a month
because that's where selena was
headquartered at the time
and my cousin who i grew up with in la
was um had in the meantime i moved to
panama
so it was great to reconnect with him
and i was spending a lot of time with
him
he transitioned into blockchain and
i was kind of following his journey
through it and when i was about to leave
selena he offered me
another consulting project this time to
help
create a commercial entity out of the
public blockchain
infrastructure that's horizon and the
goal of this
company is actually to create a
technology that
a really really complicated uh proving
system that allows
the creation of smaller blockchains but
really really easy
and inexpensive but with all of those
security features
that are enabled with a public with a
very robust public blockchain
infrastructure
so i uh i started getting
at the time i thought well you know i
have nothing to lose i don't know
anything about blockchain and it's
certainly a really interesting space
um and it's great to connect with my
cousin so
i started learning about blockchain
realized in the meantime that it's
the biggest rabbit hole chase in the
world like the more i know the less i
know
um but what i also got to know is a
really really fantastic team of people
we have a tech team based in milano
and um great place to have dinner too
and
um and so i was getting to know the team
getting to know the founders
uh the ceo is a super inspirational
visionary guy
and um dave rob and
and the whole team of people whether
it's uh the strategy team the marketing
team
uh the zen blockchain foundation um all
of the
um the business development and and of
course all of the product and
engineering just great great great
people
and when they decided to create this
entity and raise money for it
um dean my cousin asked me well you know
why don't you join as a founder and i
thought well a founder i haven't been
in my long list of career um
titles and so i decided to kind of jump
uh
take the risk and the plunge and uh jump
right in um
and again because in that transition
from
kind of one career path to another
meandering career path
one of the things that i've taken home
is the importance of working with great
people
and i just knew that i loved the team
and i loved the people and i thought
this is definitely an adventure um that
uh or these are this is definitely a
group of people that i would love to go
on an adventure with
which is what we're doing now that's
fantastic and yeah you know we just have
a few minutes left so i'd love to get to
know you a little bit better
and what is it like going through all
these incredible
experiences really you know time
consuming difficult experiences
while have while raising four kids i
mean that's not an ordinary thing to do
so tell me a little bit about how you
get that done
okay well first of all i have a better
half that um it helps me so it's not
something i do
all by myself um and
i think i was very fortunate that when
they were young i had a lot of help
um and i think that i'm ever grateful to
uh to that help i think it allowed me to
finish my studies
uh work in m a which is not a really
easy thing to do
right yeah and um and so i'm very
grateful to that and i think beyond that
i had um
um yeah you know obviously very
supportive father
of the kids as well and uh and
i think it's always been a juggle but
it's one of those juggles that
um i think maybe
i'm a very energetic person and um
that definitely comes off yeah sorry so
i i just find time um sure
and it's been great and i'm certainly
i'm certainly reaping the rewards of it
we've been in
uh you know kind of house uh isolation
um with my big kids
uh and it's been really really fun i'm
sure i'm sure but you know
still you have i mean you you can't
manage to sleep a lot and you move and
you're
moving from different industries and you
have to to train yourself
into you know sort of becoming an expert
in these different industries because
you are a leader
in these different industries so how do
you even go about doing that
you know even besides the
responsibilities of of a family
how do you go about transitioning from
so many different industries and
and being successful at doing that
i'm asking for myself yeah i wanna i
wanna get these tips
well so first of all though there are i
can assure you that there are many
nights and days where i
don't feel very successful i mean i
think in the overall yeah
i somehow managed to do it but uh but
there are definitely days
where i think ah i was absolutely
ruinous at both
um because sometimes when you juggle
between two you end up not doing heather
very well
right but i think that i don't know if
there's a magic trick except that
um i think support is one of them and
um and i guess some kind of like an
inner fire and drive
to to know that uh that i need to do
something for myself to be
meaningful for myself and so not feeling
guilty towards my kids because
um i feel like to be a good mother i
also have to be able to
um to use kind of my brains and talents
and and uh and energy i love it all
kinds of
no no no you know you know i i ask this
from a lot of entrepreneurs because i
have now the privilege during these
times they talk to a lot of really
inspiring people like yourself
and one of the things that i'm really
curious about is that then what what
motivates a person to go and conquer
these different
feats and these different mountains and
a lot of times
you don't hear the word support and
acknowledging the fact that you have a
lot of other people in your life
that are making it possible and and and
that is something that that's that's
really wonderful
and and um and very very inspiring to
hear
right before we leave we just have a
minute left but i'd love to
to know three words that you would best
describe yourself as
um and i'm especially curious to hear
what you have to say
well i gave you one energetic but let me
see if i can thank the three so i think
the first one that comes to mind would
be
uh brave um i've made a lot of career
moves but also moves coming to
israel from la so um it's it's written
on my
pendant here one of my zelda graduates
gave it to me wow
uh generous i feel like i'm generous
with my time and
hopefully try to be generous and
otherwise other way other ways
and um i mean proactive
um not waiting for things to happen
love it finally one piece of advice that
you would give to
any aspiring entrepreneur perhaps that's
coming into the zell program
or coming out of a cool tech unit or
just somebody who wants to be an
entrepreneur
the one piece of advice you'd give them
i think the first thing i would make
sure that they understand what being an
entrepreneur is
it's not about sitting around with a
laptop and thinking about neat ideas i
think it's about
risk and understanding risk and downside
um i think i would uh tell them
that to think about how they like
uncertainty and risk
definitely liat this is so great thank
you for the inspiration
remarkable journey all across um
both you know zell selena marker and
you're a lawyer that we didn't even get
to talk about and part of the israeli
bar association but
but that's for another interview thank
you for your time and the most important
horizon labs that's the one that's gonna
and now and now horizon labs of course
of course
thank you very very much for the time
thank you thank you very much
stay safe